[Music]
I don't want to sweat the small stuff
anymore yeah Pink's all about living her
best life
[Music]
well she's Nearly Naked and these new
pics shared to the gram snapped on the
pop stars family vacay pink soaks up the
Rays and a banana Prince swimsuit which
got a lot of love in the comments like
this flurry of emojis from Gwen Stefani
of course Pink's other photo leaves even
less to the imagination
[Music]
so what's Happening Here Pink says if
you haven't showered Outdoors while your
husband tries to scare you every five
minutes you haven't lived hashtag
embarrassingmoms hashtag irose for days
I have a family and I my intention is to
be the best mom that I can be meanwhile
Pink's hubby Carrie Hart offers these
drooling emojis on the pics of his
longtime love
the couple share two kids daughter
Willow and Son Jameson and while pink
crossed herself in embarrassing parent
Willow no doubt feels pretty cool being
able to be part of Mom's upcoming tour
when you wake up and all you care about
is I just want to see my kids be okay I
just want to be around long enough to
see my kids be okay Willow you're like
almost begging her to sing with you but
now she has a job on this tour right she
has a job I mean like a chore is a job
she helps with the outfits she can work
a bedazzler and mostly she just climbs
on things and then gets paid for not
paying attention yeah have you two
finalized her rate we have we're going
off of minimum wage okay that's fair but
she doesn't want to pay taxes because
it's not for real so trying to teach her
if she wants to know the real world then
I'm also teaching her how to negotiate
for herself
we're working on it this also comes two
years after pink underwent hip surgery
and double disc replacement in her neck
I'm the bionic woman now how are you
feeling I feel like a two dollar bill
I'm rare but I might be out of print out
of print but never out of style
foreign